black lives matter making some pathetic
excuses after their shady finances got
exposed the radical group taking to
twitter and apologizing for the distress
caused by inflammatory reports about
their use of donations to buy a swanky
six million dollar california mansion
they claim the home was bought to
provide a safe space for black
creativity but had allegedly tried to
hide the home's existence okay i'm going
to come to you first greg yes this what
do i find most interesting about this is
that the home was purchased for 3.1
million dollars
and a few days later black lives matter
bought it for 5.8 million dollars in
cash that's an increase of 2.7 million
who is the broker who's the help forget
the broker that's who collected the cash
who bought it for 3.1 and then flipped
it for five years i think you're gonna
have to call tide because that's a whole
lot of laundry
you know the worst part the worst part
in all of this is it's the language
you know that they go this is a time for
healing whenever they somebody does
something wrong now they go you know we
need we need time to heal after this
like was was the closing meeting when
you bought the place that traumatic was
signing all those papers you know i bet
they paid cash it couldn't have been
that you know traumatic i'm actually
jealous
i want to buy a house for 6 million yeah
if bad press is traumatic then i need to
be sent to an institution
and also can i ask you can i say
something go ahead if this is a mansion
for black creative people do they need
the pool
do they need the swimming pool part of
their creativity and joy are they doing
laughs in the swimming pool for photos
okay i was going to dana
okay and it should be more incorporated
yeah corporate offices what else are you
going to put i'll give you about fire
pit do they need a fire pit i'm giving
up you know what harold the organization
we're not going to exhibit from our laws
no we're not harold and i are passing
legislation that we both agree on the
organization continues to defend where
some of their friends have been spent
citing 3 million to covert released 25
million to black led organizations and
they say that if you question them you
are a racist for questioning them
you talking to me now yeah so the uh
they're in my mind there's one of the
things the conduct here in the name of
the organization is in my mind it's such
an awful disparity black lives matter
black lives do matter but this conduct
is indefensible uh and whomever is
responsible i hope that the organization
if there is malfeasance here and if
there's a if there's if indeed there's
illegal activity i hope that they hold
that person accountable those persons
and get the name back and try to do good
things with the organization well you
know dana harrell's talking about the
difference between the movement and the
organization and the organization
deserves to be investigated i absolutely
agree um but these people putin price
hikes is more believable
okay
okay
so that's all you have to say hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else